focus à présent sur une initiative
écologique médine loir et cher à thoré
la rochette au sein de l' usine sodi sac
depuis plus de cinq ans se bat contre
les manchons en plastique qui
envahissent les champs pour protéger les
jeunes pousses dans cette entreprise on
a créé une protection biodégradables en
cartons vendus en france et à
l'international
présentation de ce produit plein
d'avenir avec audrey champigny dont
cette parcelle agroécologiques à amboise
des manchons en carton à perte de vue au
pied de chaque cep en plus d'une
protection ils sont biodégradables
une expérimentation pour les équipes du
vino paul qui semble porter ses fruits
la parcelle a été planté en juin 2020 on
zappe à installer ensuite dans la foulée
les apportent tout simplement une
protection notamment contre les rongeurs
donc les lapins le gel ou y et non ici
c'est parce qu'on n'est pas sur une
parcelle très très très gélives les uv
on les découvre les décolorés et si leur
lait les dégradés au fur et à mesure
mais du coup c'est pas spécialement
souci puisque comme ils sont
biodégradables
si on les ramasse pas au fur et à mesure
avec le travail du sol le broyage et
cetera ils vont être dégradée et se
décomposer dans le sol ces manchons en
pin des landes de gascogne sont
fabriqués ici dans cette usine de thoré
la rochette des bobines de papier kraft
jusqu'au plafond est une machine qui
façonnent les feuilles de carton double
col pour plus de résistance et trous
d'aération étudié pour laisser respirer
la vigne breveté en 2013 cette
innovation est commercialisé depuis sept
ans par l'entreprise sodi sac alors sa
manche en mai salle produire en france
actuellement
en europe également
ce montant il remplace c'est un
alternative aux plastiques en fait la
plupart des vignerons utiliser des
mentions plastique pour protéger les
plants de vie j'ai passé pour les
pesticides pour les techs 40 sur le
plant de vigne et également pour les
rougeurs puisqu'elle lapin chevreuil qui
peuvent abîmer le plant de vigne donc
nous on travaille le craf depuis plus de
50 ans ont fait des enveloppes et des
pochettes radio et on a une idée de
semences en kraft pour participer à
l'économie verte l'économie circulaire
malgré un prix de vente de 40 centimes
soit 20 centimes plus cher qu un manchon
plastique la société vend chaque année
près de 3 millions de manchons kraft
dont 50 % à l'export